ciao 42 key today's video is kindly
sponsored by
babel the world's number one
best-selling language learning gap
hey 42 here in the summer of 1994
a boy of 17 was wandering around his
neighborhood on the outskirts of detroit
his face was glued to a small electronic
device in his hand
which was giving off a series of rapid
beeps
if this scene played out today nobody
would look twice
smartphone zombies took over our streets
years ago
but this was the mid-90s and while
smartphones had been invented
just about nobody actually owned one yet
so
what exactly was the boy holding and why
did it have him so
engrossed well as it happens it was a
geiger counter
and the reason it held the boy's wrapped
attention
was simple the rapid string of beeps it
was admitting
confirmed something that was both
exciting
and utterly terrifying it meant the
nuclear reactor he
built in his mother's potting shed was
working
but i'm getting ahead of myself to
understand how we got to this
intriguing scene in the first place we
need to start at the beginning
all parents secretly dream of big things
for their offspring
of raising a precarious and talented
child
with an inquiring mind and a first for
knowledge
but sometimes we need to be careful what
we wish for
because in the wrong hands an inquiring
mind can be a very dangerous thing
indeed
and nobody demonstrated that point
better than david hahn
also known as the radioactive boy scout
now i'm not smart enough to build a
nuclear reactor in my garden
but at least i can learn another
language with babel
with over 10 million subscribers
worldwide and content updated daily
babel is the top of the list for anyone
who's looking to learn a new language
and it's really easy to see why i
remember once walking through a busy
market in rural france
and the market stall vendors were busy
shouting and having
frantic conversations with one another
and i really wished i could understand
just a little bit more french so i could
feel a bit involved
which would have taken my holiday
experience to another level
it's reasons such as this why i'm using
babel
to learn to speak french it offers 10 to
15 minutes
short and fun classes that are proven to
get you speaking in a new language
in just three weeks there's also loads
of new podcasts stories and games
to completely submerge yourself in your
language of choice babel is great
because it works but don't take my word
for it university studies have actually
shown that just 15 hours of babble
are equivalent to a full semester of
college spanish
so if you're looking to become bilingual
for professional or personal reasons
or you just feel like learning a new
language would be a great personal
achievement for you
then i would highly recommend giving
babel a try
if you sign up to babble today you can
benefit from up to 65
off and learn a new language in only
three weeks
so click the link in the description
below check it out
grazie a sliding doors moment
is defined as a seemingly trivial
occurrence
that can have a profound effect on the
course of your life
a missed train that sees you meet your
future wife
or a drunk conversation at a party that
sparks the idea for the next billion
dollar startup
david hans sliding doors moment came at
the age of 10
in the form of a book an inexpensive
gift from his stepmother's father
the golden book of chemistry experiments
it was just a science textbook for kids
nothing more
but it would go on to profoundly change
david's life
and endanger the lives of some 40 000
others
in the process but i'll get to that part
later
the golden book of chemistry experiments
was an odd volume
it wasn't golden for a start and whilst
it was aimed at children
some of its contents were questionable
it outlines some 200 exciting science
experiments
that could be carried out in the comfort
of your home
but when i say exciting what i really
mean
is incredibly dangerous and not in the
least bit suitable
for kids for example it included an
experiment that created chlorine gas
inhale that if you'd like to know what
it feels like to experience a pulmonary
edema and another that required the use
of carbon tetrachloride use that one
topically if you're keen to irrevocably
damage your central nervous system
yeah apparently neither health nor
safety had been invented in 1960
and as soon as they were the golden book
of experiments
was one of the first things to be banned
it was taken out of print and removed
from libraries around the us
incidentally thanks to its connection to
this story the textbook is quite
valuable these days
you can occasionally find original
copies listed on sites like
ebay for upwards of a thousand dollars
it might be worth scouring the attic if
you're about the right age and
we're into science in your younger days
anyway by the time the regulators
decided we probably shouldn't be
encouraging young children to
handle potentially lethal substances in
the name of science
it was already far too late at least for
david hahn
because by then he'd long since worked
his way through the entire book
from back to front and thirsty for more
chemistry knowledge that is not carbon
tetrachloride
he'd moved on to his dad's old college
chemistry textbooks
by the age of 14 when most of his
friends would have marveled at the
eruptive force of a baking soda volcano
david had successfully brewed up a batch
of nitroglycerin in his bedroom
for those of you who haven't seen fight
club nitroglycerin
is the key explosive ingredient in
dynamite
as a random little aside for you
dynamite was invented by a swedish man
called alfred nobel the man for whom the
nobel prize is named
not all david hans experiments were
successful
he'd set up his base of operations in
his bedroom at his father's house
his parents were divorced and he
frequently caused
small explosions that left craters in
the walls
reduced to furniture to splinters and
coated the carpet
in corrosive chemicals as a result he
was banished to the basement
but it soon became clear that wasn't
going to cut it either
because not long after he moved to his
new subterranean lair
this would all make a great origin story
for a comic book super villain by the
way
david managed to ignite a sample of red
phosphorus
he'd gotten hold of the resulting
explosion rattled the entire house
and left david in need of hospital
treatment to remove thousands of tiny
shards of plastic from his
eyes but this episode earned david more
than just an eye full of microscopic
daggers
it also snagged him a blanket ban on any
kind of scientific experimentation in
the house
not that he minded he'd outgrown the
basement anyway
he was ready to build his first
high-tech full-scale lab
in his mother's potting shed even
budding super villains have to start
somewhere you know
it was around this time that david's
father began to get
a little concerned his son might be
veering off the proverbial rails
and so mr hahn did what every caring
emotionally available father
would have done in his shoes he found
someone else to take care of the problem
in this case the leader of a local scout
troop
now david was already a boy scout at the
time but
his father wanted him to take things to
the next level
to become a boy scout high priest i
think the official term is eagle scout
as you probably know boy scouts are able
to earn merit badges
in various disciplines things like
camping
level work archery and bugling you know
toolkit of the 21st century type stuff
but in his pursuit of eagle scout status
david managed to find a merit badge that
was
more to his personal tastes one in
atomic energy yep
that really is a thing or at least it
was until the scouts ditched it in
2005 which was probably for the best
because the atomic energy scout badge
was pretty much just a nuclear energy
propaganda campaign
a scout sponsored brainwashing program
put together by a whole bunch of
organizations
with a vested interest in the success of
nuclear energy
on american soil from the perspective of
his scout leader david seemed to be
doing a great job of securing the
coveted merit badge
he'd drawn some nice little pictures
representing what goes on inside a
nuclear reaction
and interviewed doctors at the local
hospital to learn how radioactive
isotopes
are used in radiology these were good
wholesome scouty activities and david
successfully earned his atomic energy
merit badge
when he was 14 years old but
over the following couple of years david
began working towards
another loftier goal as far as david was
concerned there was only one logical
next step
after knocking together a pretend
nuclear reactor
he was going to build a real one
after all he was a perfectly honed
atomic energy
expert and he had the boy scouts merit
budge
to prove it but david had a problem
actually he had too first whilst he had
long since devoured the most advanced
textbooks his local library could supply
him with
none of them contained exactly what he
was looking for
a detailed step-by-step guide on how to
build a nuclear reactor
obviously his second problem was equally
thorny
to build a nuclear reactor he was going
to have to get his hands on some
radioactive material to use as fuel
now to the average teenage boy even one
wielding an atomic energy merit badge
these obstacles would have proven
insurmountable
but as you've no doubt concluded already
david was no average boy scouts
posing as a science professor he wrote
to every nuclear energy related
organization
he could think of most of which had
helpfully included their contact details
in his atomic energy merit badge booklet
he fired off letters to the department
of energy
the nuclear regulatory commission the
american nuclear society
and the edison electric institute posing
as an enthusiastic science teacher in
search of extra info for his students
for all his scientific expertise the
english language
wasn't david strong's suit he was an
abominable speller for starters
and yet somehow this ruse worked
and before long he was pen pals with
several leading figures
in american nuclear energy a few of whom
were
almost scarily happy to answer his
probing questions about the ins and outs
of nuclear reactors
with plenty of help from his new friends
it wasn't long before david had all the
knowledge he needed
to get started all i was left to do was
to
find a large quantity of radioactive
material
and here remarkably his atomic energy
merit badge booklet
proved extremely handy once again
detailing a whole bunch of different
places a curious boy scout
might go to in order to get himself
dangerously irradiated
first on his shopping list was americium
which david learnt could be found tucked
away inside your average household smoke
detector
and so david set about collecting as
many of them as he could
well stealing them mostly but he did buy
a job lot from a large supplier
claiming he needed them for a school
project
david was able to extract a tiny amount
of americium
from hundreds of smoke detectors and
he used it to build a homemade neutron
gun a device he could employ
to create fissile material that is a
substance capable of sustaining a
nuclear fission chain reaction
in other words by shooting his neutron
gun at certain radioactive elements
he could create fuel for a nuclear
reactor
there were plenty of stumbling blocks
along the way
at first he wanted to use uranium as the
basis for his fuel
but he wasn't able to find any not that
he didn't
try old enough to drive by this point
david covered literally
hundreds of miles through michigan with
a geiger counter strapped to the
dashboard of his car
hoping to stumble across a uranium ore
deposit
just lying by the side of the road that
might sound like a fool's errand but
uranium is actually quite a common
element
around 500 times more common than gold
though it's typically found only in tiny
concentrations
when cruising for uranium proved
fruitless
david tried another tactic he found an
industrial supplier in what was then
czechoslovakia
and just bought some it really was
that easy but when the uranium ore
turned up david soon discovered that
extracting enough purified uranium from
it
was beyond the abilities of his low
budget lab
in the end he settled for using a
different radioisotope
as the base for his reactor fuel a form
of
thorium which his trusty boy scout
atomic energy merit badge pamphlet told
him
he will be able to find in small
quantities in
old gas burning camping glantons
using mostly basic household equipment
including
wire cutters batteries tin foil coffee
filters
and pie pans david was able to extract a
good quantity of thorium
purifying it to levels 9 000 times that
found in nature by now he had both a
functioning
neutron gun and a radio isotope that
in theory could be transformed into
nuclear fuel
but for reasons he didn't understand he
couldn't get it to work
when he pointed his neutron gun at the
purified thorium
nothing happened luckily one of his new
pen pals at the nuclear regulatory
commission was happy to be of assistance
explaining that david's neutron gun
wasn't powerful enough
and that a beefier radium-powered
neutron gun
would surely do the job better
david's atomic energy merit badge
booklet which by now
i think we can assume had the same
health and safety advisors
as the golden book of chemistry
experiments
helpfully informed him that radium could
be found
on old clock faces in the form of radium
paint
you may well have heard of the so-called
radium girls
factory workers who suffered from
terrible radiation poisoning
after years decorating clock faces with
glow-in-the-dark
radioactive paint david's first thought
was to tour the local junkyards in
search of
old clocks that might still have radium
on their dials
but as he drove through town one day he
noticed his geiger counter
never leave home without one kids going
absolutely
mental as he passed an antique shop
after venturing inside david
quickly hit the jackpot hidden away in
one of the old clocks
was an entire vial of radium paint
using more of his special brand of
nuclear energy on a shoestring
wizardry david was able to purify the
radium
and build a more powerful neutron gun
capable of transforming his thorium into
a fissionable isotope of uranium
in other words nuclear fuel
all of which means that at just 17 years
of age
david hahn had painstakingly gathered
both the know-how and the materials
to build himself a homemade nuclear
reactor
specifically he wanted to make a breeder
one that generates more fissile material
than it consumes
and is therefore capable of extracting
far more energy
from a given fuel source than a regular
reactor
because if you're going to build a
nuclear reactor in the garden shed
you might as well do it properly david
repurposed the material from his neutron
gun for the core of his reactor
which he surrounded with foil wrapped
cubes of thorium
and uranium powder he monitored the
homemade reactor
over the next few days noting that it
was quickly becoming
more and more radioactive
i should point out here that david
didn't actually manage to build a
genuine functioning nuclear breeder
reactor
but it's thought he probably did build a
functioning subcritical reactor
one where there isn't a critical mass of
fuel to sustain a nuclear chain reaction
but where some level of fission does
take place
in david's case we're talking about
miniscule amounts of thorium fissioned
but still it was a pretty incredible
feat
it's about this time in our story where
i circled back to the scene i mentioned
at the start of the video
a skinny kid walking around his
neighborhood his face glued to a
frantically chirping
geiger counter it seems david was
beginning to realize
his experiments might actually be a
little bit on the dangerous side
especially since he was picking up
significant levels of radiation hundreds
of meters away
from his potting shed lab if you've seen
the hbo drama chernobyl
you'll know real nuclear reactors use
control rods
essentially big sticks made of a
substance that absorbs neutrons
which are there to help slow down or
stop the reactions taking place
within the reactor david attempted to
create
mini control rods out of cobalt's drill
bits
which he jammed into his jerry rigged
reactor
but they did nothing to calm the
incessant beeps of his geiger counter
now as you've probably gathered david
hahn was not a man who was
overly preoccupied with safety i mean
his favorite hobby involved handling
some of the deadliest substances in
existence
without any kind of safety equipment
whatsoever
but as the levels of radiation continue
to climb
even he realized things were getting out
of control
it was time to shut down the operation
before he irradiated the entire
neighborhood david dismantles his
reactor
and packed most of the gear into the
boot of his car
intending to drive it out into the
wilderness and bury it somewhere
in the middle of the night if he'd been
successful
the world might never have learned about
this utterly
mad story instead david managed to look
so
shifty whilst attempting to dispose of
his dirty little secret
in the wee hours of the morning that
someone called the police
which is how it came to be that shortly
afterwards
a couple of officers opened up david's
boot to find it packed full of
all sorts of strange objects
foil wrapped powders a toolbox sealed
with duct tape
and beakers brimming with strange
liquids it all looked pretty suspicious
but not necessarily outright dangerous
that is until david gladly asked the
officers
not to touch anything since it was all
highly radioactive
the fallout from all of this was that
david's lab was
eventually discovered when officials
from the environmental protection agency
descended on the shed in huge protective
suits
they measured radiation levels a
thousand
times higher than normal and that's
despite the fact david had removed most
of the more dangerous paraphernalia
prior to their visit to make matters
even worse
david's mum worried she and her son were
about to be in some
seriously hot not to mention radioactive
water had chucked most of the stuff
david had left behind
into the bin leaving some monumentally
unlucky bin man to take it away to the
local dump
spreading the radiation further still
it's difficult to put a number on just
how many people might have been impacted
by
david's reckless actions but the epa had
a go
estimating that some 40 000 people were
at serious risk from elevated levels of
radiation
by the way as a lovely insight into just
how
slow government organizations often move
even in the gravest of circumstances
it took the epa around a year to
actually start cleaning up the site
despite their own report stating it
presented an
imminent and substantial endangerment to
public health
whilst it's easy to listen to this story
and marvel at just
how irresponsible david was and
he really was don't get me wrong there's
no denying he showed
incredible curiosity resourcefulness
ingenuity and intelligence in the
building of his reactor
alongside a dangerously high dose of
stupidity
naivety and radiation obviously
speaking of radiation david was offered
a full medical examination to
investigate just how much damage he'd
done to himself
by pissing around with highly
radioactive substances
for most of his teens but he turned it
down
by his own estimations he'd only
chopped five years off his life though
you have to wonder whether he avoided
the examination
because he was afraid to know the truth
as it happens
he would be dead at 39 the radiation
poisoning had nothing to do with it
after suffering from a string of mental
health issues
david died in 2016 from accidental
intoxication
after swallowing a cocktail of alcohol
fentanyl
and allergy medication his life had
never been quite the same after the
government shut down his lab in 1995
and his world had been rocked even
further when his mother committed
suicide the following year
david eventually joined the navy and
funnily enough ended up working on a
nuclear sub
but it turned out to be more of a case
of cruel irony than
nuclear heaven since his lowly rank
meant he wasn't allowed anywhere near
the technology that so enthralled him
he was eventually discharged on medical
grounds
david's obsession with atomic energy
never went away
he was investigated by the fbi in 2007
on suspicion of attempting to build a
second nuclear reactor
and he was eventually charged with
stealing yet more
smoke detectors we all know what he
wanted to do with those
in his mug shots after the arrests his
face was covered in sores
most likely from prolonged exposure to
radiation
it's difficult to know what david might
have achieved had he been given the
tools to explore his talent
in a more controlled environment perhaps
he still would have found ways to push
the boundaries too far
disregarding his own safety and that of
others
in his pursuit of atomic obsession
or perhaps he would have gone on to
become
a scientist of great renown contributing
to breakthroughs for the betterment of
society
sadly we'll never know
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts
link in the description below thanks